so lebte oder nicht
james ist keiner setzen so
hallo mein name ist super mann in sandra
ich darf mich heute recht herzlich
willkommen ist ein leuten die so denkst
du gesagt seid auf 17 von so einer bühne
geht einfach
wie ist das wenn man so ein opfer ist
wie ist es ebenso wie man so sprachen
lernen ja ich bin doktor über häufig auf
jeder kennt das da geht es darum dass
wir so eine person jahren und dem müssen
wir verschiedene sachen aus seinem
körper heraus operieren und werdet ihr
allerdings an ihn ran kommen dann
geht so ein kleiner dildo wozu sind die
karten eigentlich da gut dass du fragst
mich ziemlich solche karten vom doktor
wilma stapel und da steht dann
beispielsweise darauf operiert
adamsapfel und dafür würde man 300
punkte kriegen und wenn am ende dann die
meisten punkte hat alles raus auch berät
ist der gewinnt und weiß dass der
verlierer machen muss
darf ein schluck wasser trinken
es geht noch nicht loslässt auf geht's
hat die erste karte jetzt gezogen und so
rege stehen ja gesteht muskelzerrung das
ist wahrscheinlich das bändchen hier wie
band da und das ist auf jeden fall mit
am einfachsten das ist mit am
schwierigsten würde ich sagen aber okay
die sache ist wenn sammler das jetzt
nicht schafft raus zu operieren dann
geht die karte weiter an mich und ich
darf es probieren und wenn ich das nicht
schaffe damit geht es weiter mit dem
nächsten karte wenn es vibriert hat
sandra verloren hier unten drin liegt
ein kleines kino und kann jetzt nicht so
gut erkennen sammer hat der traufe
ich sehe jetzt eine karte und habe
schreibt krampf pauls einkaufsliste war
viel zu lang entfernen den stift auf
pauls am ich war ja mal arzner
ich verstehe das heißt du musst jetzt
den strauß operieren
weitergeht hinter nächsten karte ich
habe den adamsapfel den ich raus
operieren muss der ist hier oben
schrauben rein das war einfach wieder
professionell video worum zuschauern war
der iss verschoben da drin
[Musik]
das heißt er habe ampel kommt weise den
wir nicht hingekriegt so vollzieht die
nächste karte 500 punkte wasser im knie
hier vorne ist der wassereimer
vielleicht kriege ich das hin weil er
hat so einen kleinen henkel daran habe
ich schon gesehen beim aufbauen
das wird sie das kriege ich hin dass
wenn die ersten punkte ich sag's
500 punkte in meine tasche stehen
unentschieden du hast 200 plus 300 ich
habe fünf monate
bevor es gleich weitergeht mit dem
operieren meine lieben freunde habe ich
im heutigen video auch einen sponsor und
zwar das neue kostenlose mobile game dis
leid für ios und android is life spielt
in der nahen zukunft war ein globaler
kataklysmus die götter der griechischen
chinesischen nordischen und ägyptischen
mythologie in die moderne welt bringen
so kann es passieren dass sich der
stattliche odin in ein wichtiges
motorrad mädchen verwandelt oder das
angebot zum kendo experten durch die
verwendung großer lieder blöcke als
themen farbe hat bisher einen
einzigartigen pop fantasy von der
originellen gestaltung der seen bis hin
zur animation ist es halt wirklich ein
qualitativ extrem hochwertiges geben und
zudem ein rundenbasiertes mobiles
rollenspiel in dem du deine eigenen
spieler und truppen entwickeln und
aufbauen und zudem mit anderen spielern
auf der ganzen welt kämpfen kann es ist
zudem das perfekte spiel für alle leute
die grazer fans sind die auf generell
musik in spielen extrem viel wert legen
weil das einfach die komplette stimmung
bei dem spieler mal untermalt
[Applaus]
und generell ein must-have alle
strategie freaks also sagen wir zum
beispiel total checkt jetzt auf jeden
fall gerne und in der infobox mit dem
coaching dislike erhaltet ihr zudem
coole in-game rewards
das leid jetzt runterladen 1000 das
heißt es muss jetzt richtig schwer sein
voller bauch rio ace dass hier und das
sieht halt echt schwierig aus zu kriegen
ist so ein bisschen ähnlich eine
mischung aus dem wassereimer und
apfel was wir vorhin hatten
hast du
meine nächste karte gibt 700 punkte ich
habe ein gebrochenes herz operiere pauls
gebrochenes herz schon bald macht er
wieder einen scherz
erstmal damit liegen lassen das
gebrochene herz befindet sich hier es
ist auch wieder vorverschoben schau
diesmal an
das ist wieder voll in der hecke
reingeschoben worden
ok ich
muss jetzt das gebrochene herz machen
dass das komplett verdreht das heißt es
wird jetzt eine längere
[Musik]
opel-spitze gratis berufsalter er hält
auch dann in richtiger platzieren aber
das herz des echten lebens vertreten
verkackt ja
dann kommt das herbst jetzt auch
beiseite und ich habe die chance mit
einer nur 200 punktekarte uns bei einem
versenkten fuß es geht hier also um die
zange die ja unten im fußball hat auch
volker velten bei also komische sachen
drin hat hier im fuß also ich muss auch
hier ganz vorsichtig ran
siehst du mich am
[Musik]
10.6 von 400 punkte am knochen hier
glaube ich danach der liegt da wieder so
dumm
mit tiefen kind mitgefühl
das hat was
wie geht das
500 punkte schmetterlinge im bauch
paulus verliebt und sehr sehr nervös er
wird es ruhiger wenn du ihn erlöst also
ein schmetterling muss aus seinem bau
haus geholt werden ich muss jetzt
einfach alle punkte holen
der schmetterling von ford punkte meine
tasche
als nächstes habe ich 400 steifes bein
paul an einen pferdekuss rechten bein
behandelt die brille und
[Musik]
halten dadurch sehr viel
solo kann nächstes den wie viel punkte
sind es 600 schlüsselbeins verrutscht
operiert um das geld flutscht das
schlüsselbein befindet sich ja
ich brauche diese punkte
die gar nicht direkt nicht geschafft
habe so gehofft dass du gegen rauchen
und so so zittrig bist wenn ich auch
aber darauf operiert die schifffahrt
so liefert im körper selbst als nächstes
letzte karte gebrochene rippen das ist
das einzige was nachholen kann hier die
letzten 200 punkte und zumindest in
ihren preis
200 punkte wenigstens noch gab vor eine
ewig ihren punktestand eingeblendet
sander hat leider gewonnen als verloren
habe wird jetzt natürlich
selbstverständlich die wasserflasche
aufgemacht richtig teure wasserflaschen
riecht frisch
[Musik]
so liebe freunde sagt mir so viel spaß
gemacht es ist wie ein spiel was ich
gewonnen habe wir haben von der stunde
geführt und monopoly gespielt da habe
ich auch gewonnen
ja vielleicht sich selbst mal ein dass
sich eine bessere leistung
[Musik]